[Applaudissements]
imposer une thématique cette semaine on
demande de faire le bilan du années de
quinquennat je comprends pas très bien
le type il à 24% d'opinions positives je
passais plus un bilan c'est une
liquidation judiciaire
il ya un an il était à 55 % le type
hyper 33 % par an il est un type qui se
prend une mine antipersonnel il suffit
de moins vite
alors dire à ce rythme là pour avoir
encore une opinion positive en 2010 est
la sofres va être obligé de sonder les
maliens
mais bon il y en a assez de mes
atermoiements d'aboyeur réac on souhaite
que je me rattrape que je lui tresse des
lauriers pour les un an du quinquennat
deslauriers deslauriers je dirais que
son art de froisser personne sera plutôt
des bouquets garnis quoi le truc enfin
bref allez allez mode au chef bien-aimé
il ya donc un an le messie au pouvoir
arrive à mais d'où vient il
la légende raconte qu'il a été recueilli
par un conseiller général alors qu'il se
trouvait dans un panier en osier qui
dérivait sur la tulle
bref guy constatant le mollet du
bonhomme s'exclamera tu seras pédalo
monfils
la loi sur le mariage gay était scellé
alors bien sûr je rappelle aux
téléspecteurs qu'est ce que la tulle
qu'est ce que la tulle alors c'est une
sorte de neal qui traverse la corrèze et
dont la crue gorge régulièrement de
limon fertile des terrains de rugby
espace essentiel à la vie du sud-ouest
où les jeunes gamins se jette sur des
ballons en forme de suppositoire pour
signifier leur sortie de l'enfance mais
pas des pg aux
55 ans plus tard mai 2012 l'enfant est
devenu roi après 10 en dessous
bonapartisme l'alliance des nains des
gays et des hobbits chasse le veulent
sarko du palais de l'elysée la france
respire à nouveau c'est la liesse
place de la bastille à nouveau des
drapeaux algériens flotte
colonisés nous semble crier la foule
joyeuse bigarrée au son des tam-tams
breton et des newell's acia
quoi de plus naturel pour cette joyeuse
troupe que de se retrouver sur l'endroit
où furent construites les baumettes des
rois de france
[Rires]
sera est confiant le merveilleux réjean
lance son programme intitulé le yaka
bayaka à ne pas confondre avec le ak
c'est une manière pudique d'aller à la
selle deux minutes avant le coup d'envoi
d'un match de rugby
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sur l'estrade
l'amour reprend sa place lave comme ce
bac
la compagne du cher valoches surnommé
samsonite première pour les intimes se
précipite sur lui pour l'embrasser de
force un geste qui dit tout du génie
diplomatique de l'homme oui français
détenus à l'étranger moi aussi je suis
un otage
comme le veut l'histoire entre la france
et sa première dame c'est le coup de
foudre en une apparition tram est cramé
et ceci sans avoir pondu le moindre
album
paraît pour la guerre notre de gaulle 4g
forme un gouvernement de combat chez lui
vous venue l'ouverture
pourquoi aller piocher dans l'opposition
les incompétents qu'on possède chez soi
mais soucieux de ménager les agences de
notation il adresse un premier signe
d'apaisement monde de la finance il
nomme un gouvernement de stagiaires
de mémoire du siée jamais à l'elysée les
photocopies n'ont été aussi belle
entre les ministres la concorde de règne
mais après tout que pourrait opposer
duflot allongé sans sucre un agent
double crème ou jean-marc post it à
stabilo valls
les ministres plonge dans le travail ils
n'ont plus à se soucier de leur avenir
avec l'expérience accumulée ils pourront
toujours rebondir chez starbucks juillet
à carhaix
[Musique]
joie le gouvernement est au travail
porté par l'énergie sans limite de jean
marc ayrault ses talents de meneur se
révèle redoutable dans les couloirs les
anecdotes sont à l'image de l'homme tu
as plus de la cocue manger les gens là
enfin
jean-marc premier mine de france
le handicap est représenté au plus haut
sommet de l'état le plus besoin de faire
des dons au téléthon les impôts sans
charge
septembre octobre
requinqués les français retrouvent leur
travail favori c'est à dire sa recherche
novembre descendre le changement
écologique se profile pour diminuer la
pollution automobile on supprime sa
source c'est à dire les usines que les
produisent
dans le même élan on décrète lorraine
réserve naturelle florent chez
débarrasser enfin de ses hauts fourneaux
et aux ouvriers à grammont propose une
reconversion dans les métiers du futur
les locaux de formation sont prêts
la mairie n'attend plus que la livraison
des minitel
tous les ministres sont mis à
contribution assise valls qui est chargé
de reconduire les roms dans leur
écosystème naturel aux petits roms le
rhum camus t génétiquement ils semblent
s'épanouir aussi bien sur les boulevards
parisiens que sur les chanter me soir à
s'il vous plaît ici en quoi
janvier février
enfin le droit de vote des étrangers est
acceptée oh oui seigneur les électeurs
allemands sont d'accord pour nous
accorder un an délai supplémentaire pour
réduire les déficits
mais son relance le déficit n'est rien
par bonheur l'excellent montebourg est
aux manettes sur le mode des industries
de pointe qui ont fait la renommée de
l'angleterre victorienne ils pressent
l'avenir c'est le tricot les gars
mais pour vendre des marinières faut des
acheteurs alors on lance le mariage gay
coup
c'est un sujet qui passionne et qui
rassemble comme jamais ont certes un
petit groupuscule de punk monogame fait
la claque mais le pays est il assez
stupide pour suivre ces gens qui
prétendent qu'un enfant a besoin d'un
père et d'une mère pourquoi pas la
fidélité durant le mariage mais
[Musique]
dans la foulée le bo hollande obtient sa
première grande victoire contre les
finances internationales
après des mois de lutte il obtient enfin
la démission de cahuzac mais un an après
son élection le pays était sur une bonne
pente
une seule crainte entre les ministres
avec notre talent et si on se faisait
débauché par le gouvernement grec
hélas tout ce qui est beau passe trop
vite il ne reste plus que quatre ans
alors elle est pas belle la vie les
corrections de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux